little nazix i sentence you to five
years in montero state prison
lil nas x just taught a master class in
using your controversies
to promote your work and seriously
the blessings are literally knocking me
out at this point the old town road
singer was trending on monday morning
after telling fans he had a court
hearing over his controversial nike
satan shoes
and could be heading to jail but turns
out it was all an elaborate move to
promote his new single
industry baby i've grown so much yeah
the court hearing
turned out to be the cinematic
inspiration for a trailer promoting his
new music video
which drops on friday defending
your honor my client little nash
look little man look hey man what's your
name again well nice x
look nice my client little nasty had
nothing to do with this
on monday the performer dropped the clip
titled nike vs lil nas x
satan's shoes trial on youtube and lil
nas
he plays himself the judge the defense
lawyer the prosecuting attorney
and a member of the jury ladies and
gentlemen
of the jury this is about much more than
shoes
mr nazex are you gay
what does this have to do with the shoes
things first erupted
last week after lil nas posted this tick
tock
writing that his label asked him to
continue making videos
even though he had a court hearing on
monday that could end with him in jail
when you have court on monday over
satan's shoes and might go to jail but
your label tells you to keep making tic
tacs
the 22 year old explained that the
hearing was related to his satan shoes
a line of limited edition modified nike
sneakers with satanic designs that
received
a ton of backlash back in march when
they dropped
okay guys i see everybody's been talking
about this shoe
and i just want to come forward and say
nike later sued mischief the
brooklyn-based streetwear company
lil nausax teamed up with to create the
shoe but the two parties later settled
the legal battle when mischief agreed to
a voluntary recall of the limited
edition sneakers i'm just like extremely
thankful and happy
but over the weekend lil nas x continued
to tease an alleged court hearing
jokingly asking his fans on twitter what
t-shirt he should wear before the
judge and in the trailer the grammy
winner is sentenced to time in montero
state prison
a reference to the singer's legal first
name and his previous single
montero call me by your name in life we
hide the parts of ourselves we don't
want the world to see
we lock them away we tell them no
we banish them but here
we don't welcome to montero based on
that video
and this new trailer probably safe to
say
industry baby is going to get people
talking
little nazix i sentence you to five
years in montero state prison